es fehlte aber auch schon auf das wisst
ihr wahrscheinlich auch wenn er dieses
video schaut das ist einfach mitten im
leben auf youtube ein video heute liebe
leute schauen dass ich schon lange nicht
mehr gemacht haben und war youtube kann
aber nicht die gute youtube kann nämlich
für die pakete die ecke in youtube wo
man vielleicht meine entscheidung bis zu
lassen oder um leute ausgelassen oder
böse kommt ab schreibt da hindeuten ich
habe ihn in trance gewesen dass nicht
nur der händler und beläuft und szenario
sind sondern auch leon mafia auf jeden
fall hat materials auch mal wieder wie
er in den trainings wird zwar im trend
von zwang mit dem upgrade wird das
getränk vertreter hochgeladen das wird
dann so auftrete war heute morgen schon
ein bisschen weiter oben also die lage
wieder beruhigt die bewertung sprechen
für dich gern wird sich 1000 gleich zu
58.000 is life also fast giftiges funk
oder werden heute mal schauen was dieses
video platziert werden markiert ich
analysieren was da passiert ist und uns
danach was da noch kurz die kommentare
anschauen denn in den kommentaren gibt
einige leute die auch bedenken die wir
der ganzen sprach damit andere wiederum
macht aber dass ich habe überlegt seit
heute überlegt es prächtig wie lange das
du brauchst hat sich zu überlegen ob
vertreten das ist längst hat sich in
halblinker noch nie auf seinem kanal
wachstum abgebremst
wie lange hat ja wohl überlegt um auf
die hefe komma getrennt
ich habe aber auch schon auf werde es
wahrscheinlich auch immer dieses video
schaut das ist einfach mitten im leben
auf youtube es ist wirklich mitten im
leben auf youtube
laufe faktisch wertlose gespannt was er
denn da jetzt für später geplant beim
ersten rennen kann man akzeptieren ich
hoffe dass ich war so bereitet ist
eigentlich noch alles fertig gemäßigt ja
wir haben drei leute die bereit sind
ihre faust herüberkommen aber so weit
ist das alles noch im rahmen
jahreswechsel 60.000 bis leicht
eigentlich mehr juli werden
ich dachte nur 24 stunden videos auf 40
stunden bieten
das war doch was aber das war gerade aus
seinem eigenen freundeskreis passiert
hat einfach in typen richtig aus meiner
trainiere ich bin sehr gespannt wie
upgrade auf die es überrascht werden
schlägt er noch ist er gerade aufgewacht
[Musik]
gibt es heute als banker auf drei
polizisten deckard hoch für après zimmer
und wollen jetzt stürmen und wollen ihn
im schlaf hoch nehmen exakt 11
hallo himmel als ob jemand ein polizist
sagen würde durch das erste was die
polizei macht wenn du da auch bestünden
erstmals ist die fehlende qualität und
deckt euch den wir euch betatscht durch
die polizei geklingelt habe ich machen
kann so eine aussage wie sie hat eine
straftat begangen
hier stand die 24 stunden videos waren
so nicht okay sagt auch kein problem
weil sich der richtigen politik drohe
dann kommt es doch nicht glaubhaft rüber
wenn er jemanden als politisch zu
engagieren wollte daraufhin mit personen
die häufig seriös rüber kommen die
häufig autorität aus freiheit und nicht
die werk wir haben strafantrag gestellt
und bei mir vollkommen auch nicht mehr
kann
statt hier in meinem zimmer betritt mit
dem rechtlichen schutz bekommen alles
möglich einfach mitten im leben hat mir
auch er direkt für die polizei stürmt in
ein zimmer er sei überrascht worden
geschlafen polizei stück hat jetzt erste
mich so vor ort gefragt oder sondern
erhöhen anzeigen von verwunderung als
erstmal hier kleinen missgeburten warum
lauft ihr mit stiefeln auf meinen weißen
teppich passiert kommen neben drei
weiteren klassiker nummer eins
abonnenten liegt komplett angezogen im
bett wer von euch da draußen nicht
schläft auch in voller montur genau
keiner immer das bedeuten mag kann ja
vielleicht macht es bedeutet dass ab mal
anders zur kompletten als nächstes in
abel wir die polizisten mit die
gastgeber aber möchte ich das für eine
ansprache machte die polizei nimmt einen
festen gesagt er von fertig behindert
muss man das noch irgendwas sagen will
ich ein schwerverbrecher weiter die hat
420 stunden videos hochgeladen die
polizei doch gerade im verbüßt
professionell und genau den richtigen
dass die wahlen gesagt dass es so nicht
okay ist und die jetzt zu ende
gegangenen ran.de und habe strafantrag
gestellt und haben den namen gefüllt
[Musik]
es ist so ungeheuer in abrede gestellt
nicht am boden wurde gerade eben
angeblich aufgeweckt nach drei stunden
schlaf und sage jedoch nur jemand anders
jedoch so jemand der keine ahnung was er
verbrochen hat ya 48 zum lehrer wäre
nicht damit auseinander zu setzen weiß
einfach essen
die einfach mitten im leben schlecht
insel mitten im leben schauen dazu
versuchen irgendetwas sinnvolles zu
sagen das geht schwer
offensichtlich ist
also nochmals zusammenfassend ab drei
stunden schlafen mittagsschlaf lag er
immer noch sein betonen in voller montur
im bett die haare weil auch gemacht und
dazu kommt noch erschwerend hat er nicht
irgendwie ihre normale verloren wie
bevölkerung in bettlaken laclos sowie
abriss wäre nur darauf warten dass
irgendwann computerfachleute ist kann
ich es ist einfach abgeben
er wurde erst so aufgeteilt er kann
jetzt nur noch in voller montur
bereichen video mitgemacht nach an ins
bett gehen weil jederzeit mal spielen
kann ich das hier geprägt und das wird
der frösche aussehen lassen bevor die
kommentare denn wie gesagt die videos
hat mehr rechte größten schreit normaler
mensch entschuldigen was das problem
beheben hat wer bereits auf video
geklickt haben
ich dachte schon damals aufrechten ließ
aber nach der wahren abstand der
schlechten getränk her war ich war schon
ziemlich scheiße
und vielleicht kommt ja problem
die haben nicht losgegangen abo warte
das längerfristige seinem zimmer sondern
stiefel aus dem meer die nötige ruhe so
wie man natürlich der polizei ist von
dieser folge erlebt wird mitten im leben
auf youtube war wieder sehr
deprimierende nach oben